welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and that woman is joining the CW
arrowverse with a series all of her own
after making her debut in last year's
Elseworlds crossover event many of you
have been asking us about this show and
really the only way I know how to
process anything is by pulling it apart
piece by piece
up and without blinking so join me as I
break down bat woman's latest trailer to
explain what this show is what we can
look forward to from it and how it could
tie into the upcoming crisis on Infinite
Earths crossover event because even in
an elf's world
no superhero is an island spoiler
warning the case I get anything too
right and I ruin your life with the
truth let's get started this isn't the
story I expected to be telling three
years ago when Batman mysteriously
disappeared it divided Gotham okay in
case you didn't know
Kate Kane bat woman is an adaptation of
the 2006 new 52 relaunch at the DC
superhero and which bat woman is no
longer a love interest of Batman or a
sidekick but rather a Gotham vigilante
with her own backstory as a lesbian ex
military school cadet turned crime
fighter played by Ruby Rose in the
arrowverse this Kate Cain is Bruce
Wayne's cousin a nice to his mother
Martha Kate first appeared in last
year's CW crossover event alongside
Supergirl flash and arrow clashing arrow
had their body swapped to super fun and
Kate's alternate reality Batman has been
missing for three years cape is filling
in and that's the reality that this
series is set in and it looks like the
first episodes will catch us up to how
Kate got to that point so this power
trailer includes some vibrant splashy
visuals with neon illuminated images
spilling over each other kind of like
ink running from panel to panel of a
comic book that's going through an
identity crisis in many shots the colors
even reflect the CMYK color scheme of a
comic book in this injury we see a swarm
of bats as the bat suit is inlaid over
Kate's face the red light seems to come
from an emergency light neither an
ambulance or an armored truck followed
by the negatives of a newspaper front
page the headline of that newspaper says
Kane family tragedy mother victim of
hyacinth in pursuit then the sub
headline reads
children traumatized after ride of
terror and then on the far left I think
you can make out the words missing girl
now Kate's father is Jacob Kane who is
remarried to Katherine Hamilton Kane a
strong-willed defense contractor so
Kate's mother has passed away perhaps
as part of some kind of high-speed
pursuit maybe they were collateral
damage and someone that Batman was
chasing and maybe he was unable to save
them and here children and missing girl
could refer to Kate and someone else
that I'll get to later let's move on
okay and this section we get a flash of
Wayne tower which in real life is
Chicago's Board of Trade building this
Gotham City's is Chicago skyline and
bridges and streets the same way
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
did Kate's father Jacob Kane talks about
his crows security company while Kate
appears to have a good relationship with
her father it's definitely not a good
sign that Gotham has put its safety in
the hands of a private army or we attic
cops this could explain the motive of
the villain Alice
Lewis Carroll inspired villain who's
actually not associated with the Rhodes
gallery villain the Mad Hatter so if
that woman had a joker it would be Alice
Alice leads the Wonderland gang and in
the comics Alice is actually Beth Kane
Kate's long-lost sister who was thought
to be dead perhaps she is a missing girl
from that news article Kate's sister and
her ire toward the crows and Jacob Kane
is because Jacob actually benefited from
that tragedy using it to justify the
need for his and Catherine's private
security force and got them also in the
section to Capri Felicis Sophie more
bound and held hostage placed between
Kate and Alice Sophie is a Crow's
soldier who gets kidnapped and a past
love interest of Kate's from military
school her abduction pulls Kate into
this mystery on to the next clip you
take after your cousin your female Bruce
Wayne wait
Puri step away from the desk you're
seriously not supposing it was down
there
I need you to fix his suit the suit is
literal perfection it will be when it
fits a woman okay here Kate runs into
Luke Fox son of Lucius Fox Luke is
serving as caretaker to Wayne tower the
Batcave and Batman suit and tech and
since kate has now been kind of a
strange from her cousin Luke is Kate's
link to Batman's whole world you can see
Kate
moving this triangular case and if you
pause at the right moment the light
catches a string of pearls so this is
likely the pearl necklace of Kate's Aunt
Martha the pearls that you know we've
seen scattering on the pavement again
and again again
Bruce Wayne has kept his mother's
necklace in his office and past versions
of Batman that we've seen so perhaps
moving this case is how you access the
Batcave because we see Kate descending
in the Batcave and the imagery drops her
face into Batman's silhouette of a suit
followed by the final layer Kate's face
in the cowl lit in neon purple now as
you've seen in other trailers in the
series logo that splash of purple on
black is this series color scheme it
seems to be coming back again and again
again on to the final clip of this
trailer what are you doing the crows
aren't able to some see fear others hope
I see the freedom to be myself
to play by my own rules okay in this
section there's a flash of another main
regular the story Mary Hamilton
Katherine's daughter and Kate's
stepsister she's an aspiring influencer
who also works with Gotham's underserved
communities and there's another
newspaper headline that reads we bat
leave that man has returned to save
Gotham now whichever editor who thought
bat leave is a good pun should be fired
but it's important that the newspaper
credits Batman as a returning Savior
something that Kate must bristle at
because he hasn't returned she's just
carrying the torch with his gear and
this explains why she requires
customization to separate herself from
her cousin there's also a quick shot of
Kate on her motorcycle that location
should also look familiar to Batman fans
it's Chicago's lower Wacker Drive from
the famous chase sequence in the Dark
Knight now this trailer also reminds us
that this is all from the same producers
of the other arrowverse shows it's
confirmed that bat woman will tie into
this year's crossover event crisis on
Infinite Earths now in the comics crisis
on Infinite Earths was an epic crossover
storyline from the eighties in which the
anti-monitor tried to wipe out the whole
multiverse it ended with several heroes
dying and all the multiverse condensed
into one earth this event was set up at
the end of last year's Elseworlds event
in which Oliver made a deal with the
monitor is kind of the anti anti monitor
just monitor to save Barry and Kara if
Oliver will save the multiverse from an
impending crisis this was also set up
way back in a flash pilot in which we
saw newspaper saying that Barry Allen
would vanish in 2024 but that timeline
was meddled with in the flash season 5
finale to reset the year as this one in
2019 now the events could be awesome
it's gonna reportedly feature former
Superman actor Brandon Routh as an
alternate Superman as well as the famine
the animated series voice actor Kevin
Conroy as an ultimate Bruce Wayne
perhaps even the storyline might shed
some light on why Batman is missing from
Kate Cain's Gotham which looks to be one
of the biggest mysteries of this series
where the hell is Batman so it sounds
like lots of reality switching insanity
is coming in December but it sounds as
though bat woman for now at least will
stay grounded in this first stretch
dealing with Alice and this possible
crows conspiracy before joining all the
other heroes in a battle to save the
multiverse
you can watch bat woman starting October
6th in every Sunday 8:00 7:00 central in
preparation for the crisis on Infinite
Earths in December episodes will also be
available to stream free on the CW app
but why do you think Batman
Gotham and Batwoman comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on twitter
and instagram @ ee vas and subscribed in
rockstar some more theories about
everything you love thank you for
watching bye
[Music]